I didn't want to be gay,
and the main voices in my head
were just telling me,
"You'll get through this,
you'll get through this."
You have been on The Bachelor.
You have played football.
I want to be a man of faith.
But that doesn't identify
who you are.
Never thought
I was gonna come out.
I thought I was gonna die
with this secret.
The reason I'm coming out
is because I'm ashamed
and I'm sort of mortified
of what got me into this position
in the first place.
I put a poor girl through hell
of my own insecurities.
Cassie filed a restraining order
against you. You went off the rails.
I was starting to hurt other people
outside of just myself.
You want to sit down and apologize
to make yourself feel better.
The best thing you can do
is face up to what you've done
and find out who the hell you are.
I only have one life.
Something's gotta change.
The thought of even telling my dad
makes me anxious and nervous.
If you come out, you give him
the opportunity to really know you.
I backed myself into a corner
running from who I am.
Basically, what I'm trying
to tell you is I'm gay.
It always hurt more when I heard
coaches make comments or jokes.
Were you ever worried
about the coaches?
Yeah, they were like
father figures to me.
How am I supposed to be
a football player and be gay?
I still love you.
You downloaded Grindr yet?
You're a little shit.
What do you want out of a relationship?
An emotional connection.
I've never had one with a man.
You still a gay in training. It's okay.
I don't know what to do
with my hands.
Am I looking too long?
Try and shed any expectation
of what you're supposed to do
and just be you.
What you put her through
was bullshit.
It takes honesty and vulnerability.
I don't have to have
a secret anymore.
-The smile is real.
-Colton!
Since confronting it,
this is the best I've ever felt.
Everybody's coming out stories
are different.
And I'm grateful to be able to add
my story to the conversation.
If you're really worried about
what other people are gonna say,
then reconsider these jeans.
They're so trash.